思ってない。
前は千葉に持ってて、よく行ってましたね。
安子さん、富さん覚えている?
民宿の民宿。
富、富。
このおじさん、富。
私たちは千葉に行った時に、民宿に泊まった。
泊まるところが。
そうすると毎日ご覧になる。
富さん。
富さんとおばあさん、追えているね。
もう泣くなったでしょ、富さんね。
彼が初めてね、
「え、おばあさん大丈夫?野良へ」って言われた。
言われた。
言われると思いますよ、それは。
でも、後でね、見て、
ああ、すごい、お股がする。
驚かれましたね。
そう。
力は追えているね、この、富さんの。
すごい小さい頃。
うん。
力は、安子さんの馬乗ってる姿を覚えてる?
覚えてないか。
覚えてますよ。
覚えてる?
うん。
だって、足音からしてわかるみたいなのよね。
ああ、馬はね、安子さんが近づいていくところに、もう気づくんですね。
ヤスコさんの存在を。
そうだね。
うん。
サラダ、いつかですか?
ちょっと。
よかったらどうぞ。
モロヘイヤのスーツが、
おいでお腹いますか?
うん。
お腹食べてる方。
僕は大丈夫ですか?
大丈夫?
もういっぱい食べました。
うん。
何歳ですか?
25歳。
アメリカに住んでる?
はい。
アメリカに住んでるけど、日本語は低いで、英語も得意。
うん。
いや、英語の方はやっぱり今は…
アメリカ人なんだもんね。
アメリカ人なんだ。
そうそう。
3人とも孫はアメリカ人なんだ。
うん。
でも、あの、敬語とかすごい苦手。
日本語も別に普通にね、しゃべる。
うん。
ヤスコさんも日本語下手なんですよ。
フランスにずっと長くて。
私はフランス語が一番いい。
日本語は話すのはいいんですけど、書けない感じとかいっぱいあるから。
読めない感じもいっぱいある。
ルイスに聞くなよね。
本当に本当に。
私より漢字とか知ってる。
リクさんも知ってるよね。
私よりね。